Nếu đó, tôi quốc
Còn chế Liu Lan ở quảng tay Trung Quốc bị bởi sông mưa lớn sò anh ở bảo mài sắc, nước lũ or át lộ súng hả dù,
đến chìm dạ gờ quân trưa sèc ổ, nghe rất khải chào lên mấy nạn chờ trước chủ hộ.
Tương môi mùa xưa ba mưa ngày xó kháng bẩy, chính quyền thành của năm linh của tự trị dân tập tròng hóa đây biệt đam chủ.
Nếu nước lũ cũng phó lũ khẩn cấp từ các 8 lên các 1 mất cảo nhất, theo tên hoa sát,
hô chữa Liu Lan năm ở Việt hạnh châu, là công trình thủy lợi quy mô vừa trong khu vực đã bị bởi,
chính quyền khoảng tay và năm linh đã lợm các sử dụng viên tiền phương để điều khu dí hộ,
kìm chá thiệt hại và dây giờ người dân khoảng vụng vi hiểm.
Hẹn chưa gió khuuy mô thiệt hại sau sự tố bữa hộ.
Chức đó, bảo mài sắc quết qua đạo hải năm, đi vào vị mắc bộ,
rồi anh hưởng tới khu vực biên sởi Việt năm chủ quốc,
cơ quan kỹ tự trung quốc cạnh bảo, dù mài sắc suy yếu khi bảo rất liền,
hành Liu bảo kết hợp gió mùa tây năm vẫn có khẹt kết tục về vừa lớn.